Welcome to a New Year of coffee on a
Tuesday and it's going to show.
This is going to be late.
I'm sorry,
45.
So I have a reason why the Vlog is late
this week.
And that reason is of course Downton
Abbey.
I thought I would just see what the fuss
was about this thing.
So you know,
just put on one episode that was going
to be it,
but then you didn't have to marry him,
you know,
and then months ago,
before I left theater said we needed a
rat poison and I bought.
And then what am I sitting in a swivel
chair?
So I lost track of time.
Okay.
The Crawley's watching the show episode
by episode though dangerous to my day to
day responsibilities,
gave me a sense of the shows,
broader narrative for me.
The show seems to follow this pattern,
desire,
giving into that desire.
Then dealing with the consequences,
negative or positive from getting into
that desire and then starting the
process all over again with a new set of
initial condition.
Is this what our lives are really like?
After all,
we are creatures of desire each day
we're pushed and pulled by once by her
desire for things,
for status,
for people for pleasure,
small pleasures,
feelings of pleasure are the easiest to
obtain.
It's why we drink coffee or alcohol.
It's why we do drugs or lose ourselves
and upstairs downstairs British drama.
Smith,
our desires for a more sustained
pleasure for status or knowledge take
time to achieve.
We stave off the fulfillment of more
immediate pleasures.
If we can,
to work for something great,
these greater desires,
we often seek to justify it to other
people.
We tell them about our plants in that
process which may take months or years.
We're learning and growing all the time
and our desires often change.
Sometimes we realize that we don't want
what we originally set out to achieve.
We want something new,
but all the time and energy we put into
our now defunct desires and all the
people we've told about them and the
desire itself repeated so many times
that it's entangled in our
personalities,
makes any change very hard.
Here we are at the first step of the
Downton Abbey formula.
Subversive desire begins to grow within
our already organized,
like organized by ourselves,
by others,
by our social class,
until the pressure becomes too great and
we give in and opened the door to both
our desire and the consequences that
come from action sometimes actually
almost all the time.
In fact,
giving into new desires is a gamble.
We're gambling what we have for what we
want and we may come out a loser on both
counts down nabby shows us that the risk
for those with means is not nearly as
great as it is for those without though
neither can seem to resist giving in at
least once in a while.
Both the upper and lower classes in our
case,
the great middleclass must face the
truly absurd truth that our short lives
are constrained by arbitrary rules,
rules we ourselves made up and agreed to
many of our best desires go unfulfilled.
The desires made to expand us,
to open us the desire to live unimpeded
in a world of impediments well that sad
to think about.
Maybe I can cheer myself up with the
first episode of
breaking bad.